what if I was to tell
you that a game of
peekaboo could change the world thanks
to scientists we now know just how
important the first 5 years are for our
health and development especially our
brains our healthy development depends
on these top five things one connecting
two talking three playing four a healthy
home five Community all of this helps
our brains and does reach our for
potential so what's something you can do
that can really make a difference
scientists call it serve and return
that's just a grate way of saying each
time you talk to us play with us make us
laugh it not only builds and strengthens
our relationships and mental health it
actually teaches us some of the most
important life skills imagine the
difference we could make if everyone
everywhere did this